welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and this is a breakdown of obi-wan
kenobi episode 5 which finally reunites
ewan mcgregor and hayden christensen in
pre-attack of the clones flashbacks
which is really great until you realize
this is also the face who kills even the
younglings as always there are so many
subtle visual details deeper layers of
meaning so we gotta break down this
episode shot by shot for everything that
you might have missed and a reminder
that the best way to support any rock
stars is to get our empire's most wanted
shirt over at newarkstarsmerch.com
getting one of these gives you the added
option to ride in a custom shout out
that will appear in our star wars after
show wikileaks the episode opens back on
coruscant sometime before attack of the
clones we know that because anakin still
has the blue lightsaber hilt that he
used before it was busted in the
geonosis factory and attack of the
clones and he has shorter hair with a
padawan braid and yeah an arm still
intact also this is the same exact
terrace of the jedi temple where we open
episode 1 of this series where the first
jedi young lane we saw our suspicions
confirmed this episode riva the third
sister in this case the shot of the city
pulling back from the green hedges is in
daytime contrasting the night time of
the previous shot so this flashback is
more of a pleasant memory at least at
first before the darkness set in the
shot from anakin's perspective has been
angled a bit so that different
high-rises are in frame now including
this one on the far right 500 republica
the senate residence building where at
this point in history padme would be
living as a young senator from naboo
when we catch up with anakin and obi-wan
and attack the clones he says he hasn't
spoken to padme since phantom menace so
this now tells us that he spent all
those years longing for his royal dream
girl in her tower this shot echoes his
son luke's future longing as he gazed
out upon another horizon these skywalker
boys they just loved too long anakin
teases was beginning to think you
weren't coming
master good
then maybe i stand more of a chance this
time a meaningful exchange obi-wan says
that since anakin could not sense his
arrival late or otherwise kenobi's
intuition might be more sharply attuned
today than his padawans is it also tells
us that anakin might have bested the old
man in their more recent sparring
sessions ewen and hayden have been dhh
but just a little bit to remove some
wrinkles on their faces and in hayden's
face to tighten up his chin a little bit
and you can see that artificiality
specifically on hayden's smirk and
that's because mouths smiles and talking
are just always the hardest for
animators to render to be photorealistic
but really it was just awesome to see
these two together again and i'm glad
that they just let the actors act
obi-wan circle xanakan carrying his
lightsaber in one hand anakin with two
hands inverting the defensive posture
obi-wan had to take while fighting vader
in episode three vader and that duel
only using one hand this memory echoes
in the mind of darth vader as he's on
his star destroyer the devastator this
flashback is interwoven throughout the
episode structuring it as a present
lesson that both men are still learning
from and having a dialogue with vader
tells the third sister neal
grand inquisitor riva hesitates to kneel
in front of vader because this triggers
her back to that moment anakin towered
over her when she was a young lady
during order 66 rokin's freighter
returns to jabim and now we see more of
its muddy surface trails of runoff
trickling down into sediment pools later
the grand inquisitor tells riva that
they are leaving her where they found
her in the gutter in this sinkhole base
is literally a muddy runoff gutter when
they land leia rushes over to tala who's
chatting with corin and his mother you
remember them they were the refugees
hajja helped escape daiyu in episode 2.
now the character corn is actually
included among the credits of this
episode actor indie derose implying that
he might be a bit more significant he
could be or at least be based on legends
character corrin horn biological son of
jedi valon halcyon whose name actually
appears on the wall of the same base and
back in the mapuzo safehouse of episode
three according to the legends
continuity cornhorn was born in 18 bby
which would make this kid the right age
and in those stories corn would go on to
be one of luke skywalker's first
students after the battle of endor now
these expanded universe stories were
classified as no longer canon when
disney took over the franchise in 2015
but many of these stories are still
beloved by many folks at lucasfilm thus
all these legends details making their
way into these disney plus shows all
these names from the comics and in boba
fett the witches of daphner eventually
all the best stuff from the eu i think
is just gonna be official star wars
canon anyway obi-wan learns haja made it
off at daiyu and is now wanted by the
empire meanwhile we see a droid with an
astromech head and then thick hips
[Music]
passing out food i'm guessing my man
babu frick might have made a pair and i
am not complaining
there is another astromech droid that
rolls around this base but this is not
r2d2 r2 was on alderaan for all of this
obi-wan sees the wall that is covered in
jedi markings all in orvish the jedi
order sigil in the center of course but
in the top left there is no death a line
from the poem of the jedi order in which
the verse is there is no death there is
only the force also across the top big
letters be with you beneath that smaller
may the force be with you it seems like
people just write that everywhere to the
right of those directly above the sigil
the name gin altis that's the name of
the altean jedi purge survivor from the
legends books like children of the force
his name was also on the wall of the
mapuza safe house in the middle left his
screen large letters corwin shelvey
that's another legends character
actually from the 1993 role-playing game
a character who joined the jedi order
after the purge to the right of that
tiberis which could be tiberius
anderlock who was from the expansion
pack to the game from 2003 star wars
galaxy's empire divided to the right of
that beneath the sigil the phrase the
light fades but it's never forgotten
presumably another message from quinlan
voss above that to the lower right of
the sigil valin halcyon who i mentioned
before a name also from the mapuzo safe
house the legends corellian jedi from
the x-wing rogue squadron comics at the
bottom on the far left there's something
falls then the bottom middle the name
roganda is marin another jedi whose name
also appeared in the safe house and
alderaanian jedi survivor of the purge
also from the children of the forest
novel and then on the bottom right the
words only strength there are also a few
initials scattered throughout this wall
in the middle there's mf which has got
to be mace [ __ ] windu who else might
just say [ __ ] and then to the
upper right of the words only strength
is e c might be cough if you forgot to
spell his last name now here obi-wan
also finds this crate that is filled
with lightsabers remember carrying
around a lightsaber at this point is
pretty much a death sentence for any
jedi who's trying to hide in society so
it makes sense that they would just give
them up like 3d glasses outside of a
movie it makes a bit less sense no one
thought to grab one of these to fight
off the invading stormtroopers but oh
well as for which jedi these lightsabers
belong to probably no one in particular
i was thinking that long thin one on the
far left looks like mauls or maybe one
modded to be a single blade of
lightsaber but it's not exact the fourth
one from the left has a long ridged grip
like qui-gons did but again that's
definitely not exact when you put them
side by side remember these would not be
any of the lightsabers of the jedi the
empire caught or killed those were
either burned outside of the temple or
put on display in the fortress
inquisitorius i checked against quinlan
boss's lightsaber calcasta's lightsaber
caleb doom's lightsaber but by the way
that wouldn't make sense because kanan
kept his and rebels some are saying some
of these lightsabers look like the
tapered hilts of addie galia's
lightsaber or bearish office lightsaber
but put anything side by side and they
are clearly not matches i really just
think these are all spare anonymous
lightsabers they didn't put any familiar
ones in there but let me know if you
recognize any i think the one
interesting detail about this is that
obi-wan picks up the one lightsaber with
the simplest design clearly the oldest
of these the most scuffed up that's a
saber of a carpenter i think that's an
indicator that there was someone far
older than obi-wan who made it through
this path maybe the master who is
currently smuggling grogu to safety evil
lola shuts the hangar doors and obi-wan
tells them vader is on his way it's not
her it's vader he'll attack next he
hasn't the patience for siege and we
flashback from obi-wan to the memory
proving that this is a memory shared
between both vader and obi-wan the force
is bringing them together to dwell on
this particular moment here obi-wan
instructs my jedi's goal is to defend
life not take it
mercy doesn't defeat an enemy master yes
anakin does not think in terms of the
sanctity of life only his present memory
and how best to defeat them which is
what makes him so corruptible the
devastator releases two transports and
we get this great shot of the devastator
as its dagger-shaped hull pierces the
planet of jabim in the background like a
knife cutting into a tomato one of the
chipping stowaways is actually a cameo
by christina ariel host of the star wars
high republic show it seems like the
show got a lot of star wars influencers
to make cameos like what do i gotta do
don't don't you love me no okay fine i
get it i love how we get this little
flash of a trandocin family touching
their heads together which is nice
because every other time we see trans
oceans they're kind of [ __ ] over by
the back to tank where obi-wan spent
last episode healing he reviews bail
organa's hollow message i know he said
no communication but your silence
worries me if he's learned of the
children
if i don't hear from you soon i'll head
to tatooine odin will need help with the
boy i pray you're safe i'll be one
both of you
jesus come on bail speaking a bit of
code who knows who's gonna find this the
guy really needs to delegate this stuff
to a fulcrum agent get ahsoka on the
line please atala tells him about her
defection after following orders on
guerrell slaughtering four families of
14 force sensitive people six of them
children gorel is actually an outer rim
planet in the lothal sector that shows
up a few times in rebels tala reveals a
series of notches inside her blaster
holster one for every force sensitive
she gets through to safety and if you
count those notches there are definitely
more than 14 i counted like 16 or 17.
showing that for tala no amount of saved
force sensitives will be enough for her
as they gear up for battle rokin carries
a bow caster with a similar curved bow
and knobbed ends as a beaucaster that
chewie carries obi-wan decides to try to
negotiate with riva and he calls out the
fact that she knew that vader was anakin
something that should have been private
information and he realizes the night of
order 66 you were a youngling
that's how you knew you saw him and we
flashed back to that night the
background shows that young riva and her
friends are really at the far end of
that raised walkway the direction they
were running in at the end of that scene
in episode one now we learned that in
those doorways on the other end was
anakin cutting them off one of those
kids who gets struck down is actually
the same actor who played the young lane
in the amber stasis in the fortress last
episode confirming that that was one of
riva's friends and she has to see his
young corpse every day riva says i
played dead
hid with the bodies
felt them go cold a brief shot shows
riva lying on the ground her training
helmet's still wobbling it's just
heartbreaking to see all of this we see
far more of the slaughter here than the
mr anakin kid and revenge of the sith
who by the way i just learned from an
interview with an actor now as a young
man he said that as a kid he stepped
back in fear because hayden christensen
said boo when they shot that scene isn't
that sweet now i'm not a skin care
aficionado but i prefer my face to not
look like i've been lost in the dunes of
tatooine i want to take care of the
money maker well the fine folks at
geology have hooked me up with some
skincare products that i have loved
geology is a nine-time award-winning
men's skincare company that creates
simple effective personalized skincare
products for men so click the link in
the video's description and take a 30
second quiz tell them about your skin
and their team and dermatologist designs
a regimen just for you that shifts
directly to your door it's great for
folks worried about acne dark eye
circles wrinkles signs of aging they
send you a 30-day trial set that's easy
to incorporate into your routine whether
you're new to skin care or seasoned
expert here's what they sent me everyday
face wash repairing night cream vital
morning face cream and some nourishing
eye cream so far today just using this
everyday face watch has just made my
face feel more comfortable on my head
like i don't have that awkward like
the tightness that sets in in the middle
of the day it just feels like my skin is
like a nice blanket on my body i don't
know if that makes sense to you but i'm
just like aware of my skin now and it
feels nice really by designing these
things i love that they do the thinking
for me they send me just what i need and
i just have to use it and they are
offering a crazy deal right now you can
get 70 off on their 30-day five-piece
trial kit so head to geology.com to get
70 off on your 30-day trial kit when you
use the promo code or just click on the
link below that's geology.com promo code
rockstars70 to save 70 off on your
30-day trial but she doesn't want his
help and gives the blast stories the
qui-gon treatment leading to a shootout
where when you notice storm troopers are
taken down with a single blaster hit but
it takes obi-wan three whacks of his
lightsaber to take down the more heavily
armored purge trooper clearly people
worked on the show played jedi fall in
order and i appreciate that ned b uses
the kind of blaster actually used by the
battle droids during the clone wars it's
awesome to see this guy operate throws
the storm trooper up to the ceiling
throws another one 20 feet backward but
tala and ned b get hit and ned b spends
his final moments shielding tala it is
so sad but it gives her just enough time
to activate a thermal detonator and
shoot the controls on the door so
obi-wan is on the other side
[Music]
[Applause]
now while of course john williams gets a
lot of praise for his music as he should
natalie holt did most of the composing
on the show and here you can hear her
violin music so heartbreaking reminding
us a lot of the violins that we heard in
loki and of course the thermal detonator
first named and returned the jedi by
threepio in jabba's palace vader mimo
flashes back again to their sparring
session
there's no way out master
[Music]
admit you are beaten
it's over and because it's a shared
memory obi-wan answers to it by saying
it's over as if he is talking to the
memory responding in a kind of dialogue
with the memory and you probably got how
back in that memory anakin was hacking
repeatedly at obi-wan's lightsaber
wearing him down as a master knelt
mirroring luke hacking at vader's
lightsaber while vader was kneeling in
the same position in return of the jedi
obi-wan hands over his weapons to hajja
you wanna tell me
are you gonna fight without a weapon
there are other ways to fight yes this
echoes what he later tells han solo in a
new hope as the death star beams in the
falcon you can't win
but there are alternatives to fighting
so obi-wan surrenders to riva and the
shot frames the two of them so that the
heavy gun is pointed directly from riva
to obi-wan's head he says you're not
bringing him to me
i'm bringing him to you he offers for
them to end it together and riva says
what makes you think
he won't see it coming
because all you see is me obi-wan knows
in this moment the memory his thoughts
are currently dwelling upon is being
shared by vader so he assumes that since
his thoughts are being consumed by vader
vader's thoughts are consumed by obi-wan
and from here we jump back again to them
sparring there
your weapon's gone
it's over your need for victory anakin
it blinds you yeah some of the
instrumentation there definitely evoked
john williams battle of the heroes the
staccato horns playing under anakin's
opening charge during their duel on
mustafar
[Music]
you also notice anakin does that awesome
behind the back saber twirl flourish
that he uses on geonosis it's an attack
of the clones and while dooley and
obi-wan on mustafar lola tries to attack
leia or just like gets in her face
rather than smashing it like other
people would leia digs in and finds a
restraining bolt under one of its flaps
and removes it of course restraining
bolts are recurring star wars tech used
to deactivate or control droids luke had
to remove a restraining bolt from r2 in
a new hope but because leia chooses not
to smash lola she is able to use lola's
light to locate the correct cable the
transport takes off but vader drags it
back down to the ground a terrifying
amount of strength we have seen some
four sensitive characters do this before
but chronologically the most recent was
ahsoka trying to keep maul from escaping
in the final episode of clone wars
before letting him go vader tears open
the hull and notice how when we cut to
the inside of the ship to see it's empty
these bulkheads all have seats on them
had people actually been on this ship
sitting in these seats they would have
gone flying vader did not care but as we
saw from the beginning of this episode
and now in vader's entrance to this
hangar there are two freighters so the
refugees wisely fake out vader with an
empty one still if you think about it
someone did have to pilot this i assume
it was that curvy astromech r.i.p as
vader watches the real freighter escape
he returns to his memory where obi-wan
force snatches the lightsaber from his
hand you're a great warrior anakin
but you need to prove yourself as your
undoing until you overcome it
will still be a very interesting
counterpoint to the famous exchange in a
new hope when i left you i was but the
learner now i am the master so as vader
reflects back on this memory he accepts
that he still has not learned his old
master's fuller lesson about his need to
prove himself he's still the learner in
that regard but he has taken away some
lessons when it comes to staying a step
ahead of his opponent because at this
point it would seem like the episode
would be over but
reba sneak attack this episode was
actually co-written by andrew stanton
director of pixar films like finding
nemo and wally and one thing that
filmmaker is really good at is making
heroes pay up right when you think the
story is over like they can't just learn
the lesson mentally they have to
actively prove it in some physical way
for example even after marlin finds nemo
the father has to let his son and dory
tell all the other fish stuck in the net
to just keep swimming risking losing his
son again and then in wally even after
they return the plant to earth and
recharge wally eve has to show an act of
true love the way wally did for her when
she was cold and soulless and now for
darth vader he must prove he was not
blinded by a threat from behind as he
was before so this time he spins around
and stops the attack actually at first
he only uses a force to repel reba as if
she is not even worthy of a lightsaber
duel in fact you'll notice in this duel
he never draws his own blade he only
uses her half after she ignites that
second side of her saber actually nearly
sears his mask he slows down the
helicopter spin he snatches it stabs it
in half tosses the other one to rivas
says all right let's do it as they duel
i love it vader hurls a lit blade at her
which she deflects but vader uses that
one move he learned from his sparring
session with obi-wan and four snatches
the blade to force her yield and now
riva is back in that knelt posture
taking her back to her lower position as
vader towered over her when he attacked
her during order 66. the editing even
sinks these two moments the inner
cutting making it look like younger riva
is reacting to older vader and older
riva is reacting to younger anakin and
this is specifically synced when he
impales her in the exact same spot that
he did before which actually might
explain how she survives this whatever
cybernetic implants that she got patched
with before are now being seared now as
opposed to any vital organs and he says
did you really believe i did not see it
youngling
and by it vader is referring to her
hidden grudge against him reeva assumed
vader didn't remember her but he totally
does he remembers all the women children
too the inquisitors are all fueled by
anger and by vengeance and rage waiting
to take a swing at the big dog it's not
loyalty that keeps them in check it is
fear and vengeance the grand inquisitor
struts in alive and well revenge does
wonders for the will to live don't you
think he's right revenge certainly kept
maul fueled with the will to live after
receiving far worse wounds also powens
do have two stomachs so really it was
revenge and having some spare guts to
lose actually rupert friend hinted at
this on jimmy kimmel and then you got
stabbed your character got stabbed yeah
through the center stomach
one of them
one of the stomachs yes okay because
your character has two stomachs like uh
like a hippo or something half a cow
yeah they leave her behind in this
gutter and riva regains her split
lightsaber and finds obi-wan's hollow
disc with bail organa's message
now the message is damaged so riva
probably can't see this is coming from
bale or ghana unless she recognizes his
voice but in this moment she remembers
talking to owen in episode 1 and is now
putting together that obi-wan was on
tatooine who's there protecting the boy
who lives under owen's roof now it's
unlikely at this point that she knows
that the boy is vader's son specifically
like she didn't know leia was vader's
daughter but she knows this boy is
important to obi-wan and therefore she
now has a way that she can get back to
vader obi-wan assumed this episode that
vader would be so blinded by him that
he'd missed the threat from riva but
vader saw it coming obi-wan meanwhile
was so blinded by vader that he now
missed the loose end of his closeness
with riva exposing his original sacred
mission to protect luke he senses it but
only too late something's wrong yes
echoing obi-wan sensing the destruction
of alderaan in a new hope i felt a great
disturbance in the force
as if millions of voices suddenly cried
out in terror and was suddenly silenced
and these final images take us back to
where this series started the lars
homestead on tatooine and we see it from
the same exact hiding spot where obi-wan
all the time would spy on it and the
final shot lowers on luke skywalker
sleeping peacefully in his bed before we
cut to black but what i love about all
this is the context of obi-wan even
visualizing this imagery obi-wan knows
that his thoughts are linked with vader
obi-wan can peer into vader's present
mind vader can peer into his so now by
even thinking about luke on the farm
obi-wan is risking ceasing vader on
these same thoughts and exposing luke to
danger the cut to black even feels like
obi-wan desperately hanging up on this
conference call now canonically vader is
not supposed to know that luke is on
tatooine like he's not even supposed to
know that he has a son or a daughter
palpatine told him that padme died in
childbirth and lost the kid and there
was an amazing moment in the comic darth
vader number six in 2016 where after the
battle of yavin boba fett informs vader
that a rebel pilot named skywalker fired
the kill shot that destroyed the death
star and only then does vader realize
arya saw it and angrily smashes the
glass of his observation deck and that
is years from now obviously so unless
this series wants to retcon that moment
i really hope they don't because it was
awesome it's just unlikely that this
finale episode will show vader
discovering luke on tatooine but riva
can certainly know in duel obi-wan as
she attacks the lars homestead hopefully
our man obi-wan will get some backup by
a babysitter force ghost qui-gon jinn
with his very particular sets of skills
to turn riva into a redemptive character
my hope is that she becomes a gray jedi
the way i classify qui-gon jin to be
that's everything i spot on episode five
of obi-wan kenobi follow me on instagram
and twitter hey vos following the rock
sorry subscribe to rockstars more
analysis of everything you love thanks
for watching bye
[Music]
you